[Musik]
hey was geht ab und jetzt willkommen
beim ein video heute wie ihr seht bin
ich heute mal wieder ganz alleine am
start
und hier ist auf jeden fall keine zweite
person im raum
ich habe mir nämlich leute gedacht ich
mach ein werk würde er alleine das gab
es auf youtube noch nie und ich frage
mich auch wie das funktionieren soll
vielleicht passiert ja jetzt gleich ein
wunder und plötzlich ist jemand neben
mir habe ja leute ich habe heute nach
wie duncan haben wir schon mal kein
video mehr gemacht auf jeden fall habe
ich heute endlich mal wieder die
bezaubernde marie dabei das habe ich
auch genug gelobt für das heutige video
reicht erstmal wieder und wir haben uns
was wirklich sehr gut besonders weil ich
habe es ja schon erwähnt das gab's auf
youtube wirklich noch nie ist absolut
nicht ausgelutscht
aber ich habe so etwas noch nie gemacht
deswegen hat sich hier gerade
wundervolle natürlich wissen dass man
das was man sieht ich noch was drauf
steht oder rachel müssen wir das tor
machen
beide brauchen jetzt das war nicht gut
also nicht so dass sieht man besser doch
man kann das lesen also dass man fast
gar nichts drauf steht da wo es
aufstehen und alex dem was man auch die
hellsten farben gegeben diese pflanzen
denken
das liegt daran weil ich nur zwei stifte
ja in der ganzen wohnung war ich einmal
blau und einmal grün und das blaue war
sogar ein kollege für alle die wert
würde er noch nicht kennen marie erklärt
das ganze jetzt in zehn sekunden ist
windig und zeit auf dem feld ein paar
aussagen geschickt und dann und dann
sagen
das er machen wir den namen angenommen
genau hier hat bei mir über in step
allerdings kommentiert wenn ihre fenster
und ich folge macht es auf jeden fall
und wir fangen jetzt anders einen daumen
nach oben dafür weiß ich mache einfach
also wir suchen uns jetzt immer
gegenseitig eine frage raus und der
andere leser müssen meint das hochhalten
also die erste frage ist schon gut ich
habe sofort ist sofort das erste was ich
lese nehmen mich wäre würde er hat den
ganzen getränkeautomaten auf kaufen und
die getränke dann alle leute auf der
strasse teurer verkaufen als man sie
selber gekauft hat war sind 321 was du
jetzt gezeigt alec mich als wenn ich
einen getränkeautomaten gehe und die
getränke aus sechseinhalb stunden später
wäre würde er in die unterwelt von
anderen acht monate lang tragen einmal
größer als 1 million
das kann doch gar nicht hat sie nämlich
sogar schon mal meine jahr aber so an
falls das nicht gesehen habt aber das
war nur ganz kurz für ein video hier mal
kurze ausnahme wenn ihr das sehen wollte
haye denkmal logisch gemacht wenn ich
jetzt deine unterhosen als nur das wir
jemals das thw auf dauer weiter
das was anderes
man erkennt das erkennt man doch das
erkennt man uns geschrieben
wer würde er ein ganzes jahr lang ohne
geld auskommen halt nicht shoppen urlaub
etc es mit bitte schöne grüße an ronja
hast du auf mich zu und sagten nein das
wird nicht klappen mädels heute müsst
euch vorstellen ich schneide das zwar
aber das dauert gerade echt wieder
extrem lange ja hallo ich muss ja auch
jeder kommentare hoch also immer das
muss halt laden
noch besser schnitten würde er eine
rolle werden wollte er einen monat lang
leben
hey ich kann nicht ungelegen dass mein
job ja aber trotzdem manchmal hängt ja
bist du auch weil ich kann deshalb nicht
weil ich dann zu einem monat praktisch
kein geld für den öl und natürlich nehme
meinen über mac programmen aber naja ok
dann heute ja und dann hat jetzt sagt in
der mitte youtube-videos und schläft
gehen morgens 11 3 macht nicht ich
studiere noch nehmen wollen alex ist
sehr fleißig wer würde er in den
mcdonald's fahren und dann rufen alle
hätten hier bitte ich erste mal happy
mir spaß ich kann da eh fast nichts
anderes essen weil ich weiss nicht
verwüstet mal da hin wenn ich zu sagen
eine kleinigkeit geht noch und holte zum
happy meals oder so
dann will die spielzeuge haben was soll
das denn nicht jeden tag ich glaube
jetzt einfach aus protest jetzt sicher
achter warum sollte man sollte ich den
einwohnern stufen
naja weil die junge bist und das nicht
ganz so dramatisch von den hafen zum
beispiel werden bei mädchen okay das
wetter soll ja ich bin jetzt habe jetzt
ziemlich ausgewählt jetzt bin ich wieder
da
selina schreibt werbe der er ein jahr
ohne seine fans auf youtube auskommen
schöne grüße silvia super frage ich habe
schon bevor ich was ich dazu sage du
hast ja gar keine hab ich da mal ganz
schnell
700.000 er wird ein spaß
allerdings reichten die kommentare
schreiben alex morph mich nur das stimmt
weißt du wie kann ich mich dann doch
gerne austragen aber nicht auch weil man
du willst und aus lithium ja aber ich
würde mir auch vorstellen keine ahnung
irgendwann mal woanders zu leben als
hier aktuell aber am liebsten nach
spanien auswandern oder nach aber ich
habe mich gebildet eben deswegen ohne
spaß diese fragen versteuern mich leicht
die ich hier lese zum beispiel wer würde
er eine nacktschnecke zerschneiden und
dann essen was hast du denn welcher
mensch macht sowas ist die frage also
ich glaube wenn sie jetzt wirklich hart
auf hart kommt und man das wirklich
machen müsste eine von uns und wir
können ja mal sagen also dann würde ich
das auch machen
ich habe auch schon mal irgendwo rum
gegessen hast noch besser schnitten und
zwar habe ich den genommen der war noch
am leben und wir leben mit dem kopf
zuerst in den mund und damit man ihn
sofort tötete damit er nicht wieder aus
dem wagen hoch krabbelt habe ich drauf
gewissen und dann war der kopf halt ab
und dann hat er auch nichts mehr gespürt
und so weiter und dann konnte ich den
ganzen ruhr verspeisen wollte ich nur
mal kurz zu sagen so jetzt davor ihn
auch die letzten tage aus das ding ist
weiter bei mir wird es auch stimmen
meiste und deswegen macht es auf jeden
fall hier an dieser stelle deutlich mehr
sind oder ob wir kommen noch ein zum
abschluss noch einmal als absicherung
wäre würde er bei twilight wein und
sport diese filme nicht hast du die alle
filme die menschen viel zu tun haben
ich würde sagen es steak langweilig
sagen letzten zweihundert wirklich war
voll ein zweiter kennt früher so und da
danach trug und ich liebe mich und ich
glaube er hat selbst von der medizin
versteht dass auch das viel besser und
ich habe aber einzig den letzten teil
von twilight gesehen habe ich noch so
aktuell habe ich geheult ja bei der
rasen veranstaltung dann sind
vorhergesagt sicherheit leider darf sich
freuen das ist ja schlecht hier so leute
ist ja auch egal
auf jeden fall war das ein sehr tolles
wäre würde er video wenn man so was sie
machen sollen dass wir ordentlich die
daumen nach oben schauen auf jeden fall
bei uns sondern vorbei auch bei marie
instagram sehr sehr schön kann auf jeden
fall mal vorbeischauen und sich die
police an gruppen
wir sehen uns dann wollen wieder morgen
gibt's neues video ich wünsche ihnen
einen schönen tag und schreib mal
weitere wer würde erstmal hier drin